que ce serait mentir de dire que on a
pas peur pourquoi parce que le risque
est là mais en opération il y a le
courage collectif c'est quelque chose
qui est redoutable en termes
d'efficacité parce que ça veut dire que
l'on est prêt à aller se faire flinguer
pour aller sauver un collègue tous quel
comportement adopter face à un preneur
d'otage comme on négocie-t-on avec lui
et ce qu'on peut mentir et comment
gère-t-on ses émotions lorsque des vis
sont en jeu celle-ci Hugo j'espère que
vous allez bien on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour un cinquième épisode de
cette série consacrée à la découverte de
métiers d'exception après notamment
François Hollande sur la fonction de
président Thomas Pesquet sur la vie dans
l'espace ou encore max Verstappen le
champion du monde de Formule 1 sur les
coulisses du quotidien d'un pilote
aujourd'hui on se retrouve donc avec
Christophe Coppens un ancien négociateur
du raid l'une des d'élite de la police
nationale au passage le dit à chaque
fois mais si ces vidéos vous plaisent
évidemment pour nous soutenir et pour ne
pas louper les vidéos suivantes pensez à
vous abonner à cette nouvelle chaîne
Youtube et activer les notifications
chez mais c'est pas encore le cas pour
ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes je
crois que j'ai tout dit je vous laisse
donc tout de suite avec
première question déjà comment
devient-on un négociateur du raid faut
savoir que c'est véritablement en effet
un métier et ce n'est pas le cas quand
je suis arrivé au raid puisque c'était
une spécialité il y avait déjà un groupe
négociation qui était en place mais pour
en faire un métier en fait il faut
structurer formaliser les connaissances
s'appuyer sur une université construire
un véritable cursus donc avec des
épreuves des domaines extrêmement
spécifiques là en l'occurrence
l'ensemble des sciences humaines il faut
passer par la fac de médecine pour faire
de l'expertise mentale et tout ça en
fait ça nous donne un ensemble donc de
savoir qui nous permettent de les
évaluer et ensuite donc d'en faire un
véritable métier reconnu au répertoire
national certification professionnelle
donc c'est un véritable métier de
négociateur de crise et pour information
il est ouvert uniquement dans les Forces
Spéciales police et gendarmerie donc
GIGN pour la gendarmerie et le raid pour
la police et voilà et il y a personne
d'autre donc qui ne peut accéder à cette
formation là qui maintenant est un vrai
vrai métier de négociateur quelle est la
qualité principale à avoir
il y en a quand même quelques-unes
indiscutablement la première de toutes
c'est l'écoute et d'ailleurs pour
information si tu regardes bien la tenue
des négociateurs du raid sur le l'une
des manches comme tous les opérateurs du
raid et bien il y a la panthère noire
celle qui est donc l'animal totem de
l'unité mais sur l'autre côté il y a un
logo qui est avec
œdipe et le SMX face au Sphinx alors ça
remonte à la mythologie le Sphinx se
mettait en péril la cité il posait une
énigme et
œdipe a trouvé la réponse à cette énigme
par la même donc a réussi à supprimer le
le la menace sur la vie là on sait on a
trouvé c'était notre psy qui avait eu
cette très bonne idée et il avait il
s'était dit bah voilà ça serait une
bonne représentation pour les
négociateurs et bien ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que on a en fait une une phrase
qui se trouve sous le blason et qui est
l'écoute et notre arme c'est
véritablement en fait la qualité numéro
1 pour les négociateurs c'est pas de
forcément de bien s'exprimer d'avoir un
stock verbal incroyable etc tout ça
c'est des plus mais par contre par
contre l'écoute est vraiment quelque
chose de formidable ensuite il faut de
la vivacité d'esprit quand même parce
que à plein de moments on est surpris on
est surpris par la personne qui est en
face de nous elle peut nous interpeller
sur des choses qui sont assez
dérangeantes il faut savoir travailler
en équipe c'est très important et puis
cette agilité intellectuelle bon là où
on l'a pas si on n'arrive pas à
maîtriser son stress et puis si on
n'arrive pas donc à l'utiliser on va
dire intelligemment pour justement en
faire une force en faire quelque chose
qui te donne et bien là à ce moment là
ouais c'est très pénalisant alors on
peut s'entraîner bien sûr mais quand
même c'est mieux si on est stable dès le
départ avoir une vie de famille c'est
possible
alors non seulement c'est possible mais
c'est justement rechercher lorsque l'on
fait du recrutement on cherche à voir
des gens stables donc des gens qui ont
envie de rentrer à la maison le soir ce
que tu imagines bien que si on avait des
aventuriers qui voulaient tout le temps
à être dans le risque et puis dans le
challenge à risquer leur peau il
pourrait être extrêmement dangereux pour
l'ensemble des autres opérateurs mais
également donc pour la réussite de la
mission donc on a cherché à avoir des
gens déjà stable alors après l'alchimie
c'est justement d'arriver à les
maintenir dans cette stabilité de vie et
donc là par contre c'est très compliqué
compliqué parce que on est au service de
l'État on est ce que l'on appelle
l'ultima ratio l'ultime recours de
l'État donc sur la partie police donc
pour résoudre des crises et à ce titre
là on est conviable à souhait donc ça
veut dire que on doit avoir des gens qui
sont formidables dans notre entourage
pour accepter que pendant 5 ans
renouvelable une fois 10 ans au total et
bien on puisse être justement totalement
à disposition de l'État après
il faut bien se dire une chose c'est que
on incarne quand même quelque chose de
très fort également pour les proches
pour la famille etc on incarne des gens
qui vont aller sauver d'autres personnes
donc par la même il y a une très grande
indulgence à l'égard justement de nos
contraintes voilà je pense qu'il faut
avoir des gens intelligents avec soi
comment est-ce qu'on gère ses émotions
les émotions sont extrêmement
perturbatrices extrêmement donc ça veut
dire que si on n'est pas capable de les
discipliner là à ce moment-là ça devient
un véritable handicap pour nous par
exemple on peut être extrêmement ému par
une mère qui nous supplie d'aller
récupérer ses enfants qui sont pris en
otage par son ex-mari il faut savoir
discipliner nos émotions plus facile à
dire qu'à faire mais la réalité c'est
que physiquement on fait comme si on
posait nos émotions à la porte de
manière à ne pouvoir utiliser que les
émotions qui nous intéressent parce
qu'il faut créer du lien avec la
personne et pour ça il faut savoir
utiliser les émotions parce que sans
émotion pas de prise de décision je
crois que ça serait mentir de dire que
on n'a pas peur pourquoi parce que le
risque est là il faut bien voir que
c'est parce que les gens échoué avant ce
qu'on appelle les prix moins
intervenants parce qu'ils ont échoué
avant à ce moment on n'a pas le choix
faut qu'on y aille nous donc ça veut
dire que c'était très dangereux sinon on
nous appellerait pas on appellerait pas
la cavalerie donc on y va
et forcément les situations elles
peuvent être par exemple de voir amener
l'individu à ouvrir sa porte et puis te
présente le fusil tu vois en face de la
figure et n'importe qui aurait peur dans
des conditions comme ça sauf que on a
cette espèce donc de discipline
personnelle qui est que c'est très très
bien organisé on a des snipers qui nous
couvrent on a le groupe d'assaut qui est
pas loin il y a des chiens d'assaut qui
peuvent être lancés à tout moment et
puis on fait pas des choses qui sont non
plus tu vois totalement superflu ou
stupide alors sur la question
de la peur en elle-même
la peur les salvatrices je crois que le
jour où on a plus peur en opération ce
jour là il faut se poser la question de
savoir si on reste ou si on part il faut
se dire attention on peut être dangereux
véritablement pour les autres alors
ensuite sur la question du courage juste
une chose
quand on est recruté on est recruté avec
des tests et donc on nous teste sur le
courage bien sûr
sur tout un tas de paramètres mais entre
autres le courage mais en opération il y
a le courage collectif
c'est quelque chose qui est redoutable
en termes d'efficacité parce que ça veut
dire que l'on est prêt à aller se faire
flinguer pour aller sauver un collègue
tous quel que soit la fonction que ce
soit un technicien un opérateur
d'intervention du groupe d'assaut que ça
soit un négociateur ou le médecin
urgentiste n'importe qui en fait sera
prêt à aller sous le feu pour pouvoir
sauver un collègue ce courage collectif
il nous oblige il nous oblige donc
quelque part il nous porte en fait à
être encore plus courageux donc la peur
est là mais elle est raisonnée le
courage est là mais il est discipliné
par quels moyens de communication est-ce
qu'on négocie alors on essaye le plus
possible en fait de de travailler à
distance avec le téléphone pourquoi
parce que tu le sais il y a plusieurs
modes de communication il y a la
communication verbale donc c'est ce que
je dis quand je parle est-ce que je
parle en français en anglais etc est-ce
que j'ai un langage sophistiqué pompeux
ou est-ce qu'au contraire j'ai un
langage tout à fait accessible voire
pourquoi pas de l'argot à certains
moments etc donc ça c'est la partie
verbale ensuite il y a un paramètre donc
qui est le Para verbal le Para verbal
c'est notamment la musique que tu prends
quand tu expliques les choses tu sais ça
fait des variations on appelle ça de la
prosodie c'est la vitesse d'élocution
c'est le temps que l'on utilise bien
quand on est au téléphone il y a que ces
deux modes là en fait qui réellement
sont accessibles à la personne
donc tout ce que l'on va discipliner
autour de la voix la troisième mode de
communication c'est le non-verbal et là
par contre tu peux pas tricher quand tu
as peur ça se voit ça se voit tant de
figure ça se voit tu vois si le type il
dit bon bah écoute voilà ben je vais
tuer l'otage donc pour réduire ces
éléments là on travaille par téléphone
le plus possible une fois que ça a été
géré par téléphone à ce moment là quand
on a suffisamment de garantie on va
aller faire un face à face avec la
personne quels sont les types
d'interventions
du plus simple au plus complexe le plus
simple c'est quelqu'un qui voudrait bien
sortir mais c'est pas comment faire donc
il est retranché chez lui il a menacé
bon voilà on le prend au sérieux parce
que on pense qu'il est en effet armé et
donc on appelle le raid pour voir si on
peut débloquer la situation et il est
bien content de se rendre donc c'est des
situations
ultra simple ensuite tu as dans les
situations qui sont pour nous aussi les
moins dangereuses à notre niveau tu as
par exemple les suicidaires les
suicidaires c'est quelqu'un qui veut
qu'il est auto-agressif donc qui veut se
tuer et là à ce moment-là bon
normalement on n'a pas de danger
particulier
on va pas aller au 15e étage avec lui se
mettre à côté du vide pour comme dans
certains films mettre la menottes en
disant bon on saute tous les deux OK ou
on saute pas non c'est du cinéma tout ça
la réalité c'est que on essaye justement
d'être dans des situations qui
permettent de stabiliser notre
suicidaire et puis de faire en sorte
donc qu'il sur les signes donc à
va revenir en arrière et à laisser son
idée de ce de se tuer donc ça c'est
relativement facile ces choses là et
puis après tu as ce que l'on appelle les
forces nés donc le forcené c'est un
individu retrancher armé qui est quelque
part donc ça peut être une situation qui
poste homicide il a tué quelqu'un il a
et ensuite il est retranché il sait pas
comment sortir de cette situation la
police est arrivée débloquer à
l'intérieur et souvent en fait ça peut
déraper sur du suicide derrière tu peux
avoir également une fortionné de combat
ce qui est le plus fréquent et là à ce
moment-là ce sont des gens qui ont une
détermination absolue parce qu'ils en
ont marre de se faire avoir parce qu'ils
en ont marre que on les floue que la
société les malmaines etc qui ont décidé
en fait de se battre et donc là c'est
très très compliqué parce que souvent
ils sont jusqu'au boutiste donc là on
sait très bien qu'on peut y laisser des
plumes face à ce genre de choses ça
c'est pour la partie forcenaire
retranché armé seul et puis tu as tout
le volant le volet plus exactement les
prises d'otage prise d'otage qui peuvent
être ce qu'on domestique prise de dash
domestique c'est le gars sur ses gosses
sur sa femme etc ou son ex-compagne ça
peut être extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'il peut y avoir des suicides
altruistes ok vous êtes malheureux je
suis malheureux je vous tue je me tue
derrière etc donc tu vois on peut partir
sur une situation toute bête de de prise
d'otage qui en fait va dégénérer sur un
suicide collectif et puis ensuite on a
les prenantes criminels alors pendant
quelques années il y a eu des gens
encore qui essayaient d'attaquer des
banques et qui se faisait piéger à
l'intérieur et puis tu as également les
prises d'otages terroristes ou là on est
dans un degré en fait de gravité de
complexité qui est très très important
il faut faire attention parce que la
négociation peut être à double tranchant
c'est à dire que on peut en fait offrir
une tribune à ces gens-là une tribune
médiatique notamment qui est totalement
normal parce que de toute façon derrière
ils tuent les gens donc la question
qu'on se pose c'est est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas sur soi à la négociation
et intervenir très vite à quoi ça
ressemble un début d'intervention
la première des choses et ça c'est du
systématique c'est le renseignement en
amont parce que plus tu vas récupérer du
renseignement plus tu vas pouvoir avoir
une stratégie intelligente par rapport à
ton auteur vraiment quelque chose que
l'on doit particulièrement bien soigner
deuxièmement il y a des personnes qui
sont autour potentiellement de cette
personne en crise si c'est la famille ou
si c'est des témoins ou des choses comme
ça ou des gens qui ont pu s'échapper de
la prise d'otage ces gens-là vont nous
renseigner sur le mode opératoire sur le
comportement de la personne peut-être
sur son identité et si on a l'identité à
ce moment-là tout un tas de choses sur
le profil médical psychologique
psychiatrique si on fait de l'expertise
mentale dans la formation des
négociateurs c'est parce que justement
on a besoin de d'être très très bon dans
la lecture de tout un tas d'indices
parce que tout parle ok tout parle la
manière dont on est habillé le choix
qu'on a fait du monde plutôt qu'une
autre etc la manière dont on se présente
toutes ces choses là sont d'excellents
indicateurs donc une fois que l'on a
balayé justement ces informations qui
permettent un petit peu de profilés et
peut-être même de profiler avec le
dossier pénal de la personne tu vois les
antécédents judiciaires à ce moment-là
on se concerte entre nous sur la
stratégie que l'on va utiliser pourquoi
parce que c'est pas le travail d'un
homme la négociation c'est une équipe
qui fonctionne et l'équipe elle doit
c'est une intelligence collective et
donc elle doit amener à ce que en
débattant rapidement entre nous on
puisse se dire tiens ça c'est une bonne
idée ça par contre vraiment il faut pas
qu'on aille dessus donc il y a des mots
tabous il faut surtout pas aller par
exemple parler de la famille parce que
ce gars-là justement il est en trop
grand conflit il y a des mots totems il
y a des choses qui sonnent bien à
l'oreille du gars par exemple le fait
d'être dans une proposition d'aide
comment est-ce que je peux vous aider
combien de temps dure en moyenne une
intervention
c'est extrêmement aléatoire mais on a
fait quand même des statistiques là
dessus
on sait que en moyenne du temps où
j'étais en fonction comme patron des
négociateur on avait une un forcené qui
était résolue en quatre heures tu vois
en 4 heures le type en règle générale
c'était rendu il y avait une espèce de
courbe tu vois au début très motivé
plein d'adrénaline etc puis au bout d'un
moment l'épuisement parce qu'il faut
payer la note plus tu as de l'adrénaline
plus tu consommes de l'énergie si tu
consommes de l'énergie et que tu en
remets pas dans la machine forcément tu
pars donc on affaiblissement on
épuisement donc
on a quatre heures à peu près pour
résoudre une situation de forcener ce
qui est quand même relativement long et
on a 10 heures pour une situation de
prise d'otage 10 heures pourquoi parce
que d'abord nous on prend beaucoup de
temps on prend beaucoup de temps parce
que il y a tout un tas de choses que
l'on va mettre en fait on va appeler ça
de maitrisation c'est à dire on fait on
pose des petites gouttes à certains
moments dans le cerveau dans la
discussion du bonhomme OK et ça va
percouler après au niveau des neurones
OK et donc on va parfois le faire douter
à d'autres moments on va le rassurer à
d'autres moments on va lui proposer
quelque chose de totalement incongru et
là il va être tu vois dans une espèce de
perturbation cognitive il sait pas au
fond ce qu'il doit faire etc et le temps
de résignation le temps de résignation à
partir du moment où il a un levier qui
est celui des otages ce temps-là est
long le temps de résignation tu vois
c'est le sien c'est pas le nôtre il faut
pas qu'on nous dise hé les gars dans
deux heures il faut que ça soit résolu
la prise d'otage et quels sont du coup
les grandes techniques de négociation
qui existent la communication avec une
personne en crise c'est déjà arrivé à
comprendre quel est son besoin
et tu vois ça ça prend du temps pourquoi
parce que il fait toujours des demandes
je veux ça je veux pas être expulsé je
veux que ma femme revienne à la maison
par exemple ce genre de choses ouais
d'accord c'est pas possible ce genre de
chose si une décision d'expulsion il est
expulsé point loyer depuis 2 ans
il a il a posé le cadre voilà donc par
contre quel est le besoin est-ce que son
besoin c'est réellement de récupérer son
de garder son appartement il sait qu'il
l'aura pas c'est pas c'est une fausse
demande c'est un paravent la réalité
c'est que il veut faire en sorte qu'on
le respecte par exemple tu vois donc
cette notion de respect est plus
importante que tout donc je vais
travailler sur le respect sur cette
notion de respect avec lui et non pas
sur la demande est-ce que on peut
négocier avec des terroristes
d'expérience parce que on a beaucoup
fréquenté les unités spécialisées les
unités spéciales qui étaient sur ces
profils là terroristes on est tous
convaincus d'une chose c'est que soit on
doit on a l'obligation de neutraliser
très vite la personne auquel cas les
négociations peuvent servir de prétexte
mais il y a plein de situations
également ou c'est intéressant d'obtenir
des infos également pendant la
négociation parce que peut-être qu'après
on les aura plus il peut lâcher des
choses qui sont intéressantes parce que
la police judiciaire elle va exploiter
l'ensemble des éléments et donc et bien
on a des gens qui peuvent faire des
confidences à certains moments qui ne
feraient plus après pendant l'enquête
donc ça peut être un élément qui est
intéressant et puis ensuite il faut
donner sa chance également
à la possibilité de sortir vivant on
comprend mieux des processus d'adhésion
tu vois dans doctrinement et on comprend
également que on a plein de préjugés
c'est préjugés ils sont faux tu vois on
pourrait s'imaginer que le type il
fréquente une mosquée radicale pendant
trois ans il fait de plus en plus de il
rentre de plus en plus de services etc
non pas du tout des fois la conversion
elle se fait en 15 jours quoi il y a une
blessure narcissique le type là se dit
bah tu sais pas je vais aller avec les
autres voilà je sais qu'ils font des
coups je vais avec eux peut-on mentir
quand on négocie
alors si tu penses négociation
commerciale oui le mention est utilisé
quand tu fais du One Shot à ce moment là
il y a souvent du mensonge par omission
j'oublie te dire que par exemple si tu
achètes une imprimante les chorales les
cartouches coûtent super cher et puis il
y a très peu de quantités à l'intérieur
et ça va te revenir pour une fortune tu
vois elle vaut pas cher mais en même
temps payer très cher en revanche sur la
négociation avec l'humain au sens large
gestion des conflits négociations
criminelles bien sûr négociation
familiale et tout ça le mensonge est
vraiment la pire des solutions la pire
des solutions parce que menteur une fois
menteur tout le temps et à partir du
moment où tu as trahi quelqu'un
la rupture de confiance qui est entre
vous est terrible alors souvent on peut
se retrouver entraîner à mentir parce
qu'on est un peu pris au dépourvu etc il
faut s'excuser dans ces cas-là bon j'ai
merdé j'aurais pas dû dire ça j'aurais
pas dû raconter une ânerie je suis
désolé je savais pas quoi répondre c'est
venu spontanément parce que j'avais
honte et là à ce moment-là ça peut être
admissible si tu veux que tu es menti
parce que tu fais une reconnaissance de
ton mensonge tu fais la veux en fait
d'une faiblesse particulière l'erreur
est humaine ok pas de souci en revanche
en revanche si tu mens sciemment sur une
une situation
interpersonnelle là à ce moment-là c'est
catastrophique moi je déconseille très
fortement on peut tout dire il suffit de
trouver le bon moment et la bonne
manière de dire
quel est le pourcentage de réussite
fait plus de 350 opérations je l'ai dit
on avait 80% de taux de résolution par
la négociation ça veut dire que tout ce
que l'on avait été chercher dans
l'ensemble des sciences humaines et que
l'on avait aggloméré ensemble pour en
faire une méthode
c'était particulièrement efficace ça
veut dire donc on avait à coup sûr
quasiment 8 fois sur 10
la bonne compréhension de ce qui était
la problématique la bonne approche le
bon timing lorsqu’une personne se rend
qu'est-ce qui se passe après il est
important en fait de que tout ne
s'arrête pas au moment la personne est
interpellée où elle se rend le
négociateur a besoin d'aller voir
d'aller voir la personne a besoin de
discuter a besoin de de montrer que
c'était pas du des histoires tu vois du
flan là ce qu'on avait fait les heures
que l'on a passé ensemble vraiment je
suis intéressé par le problème et
souvent on valorise le fait que la
personne se soit rendue en disant c'est
bien c'était une bonne solution voilà et
donc tu vas pouvoir t'expliquer
maintenant les enquêteurs vont être là
ce sont des gens bien tu verras ils vont
vraiment prendre des éléments ça soulage
quand même grandement la personne merci
beaucoup pour ton temps c'était très
très intéressant Hugo c'était
passionnant j'espère que ça donnera des
vocations
[Musique]